this woman uses tiny brushes to create
ultra realistic portraits that are just
an inch tall and half an inch wide on a
curved canvas
my name is vivian zu rahe and i am a
nail art scientist
that's right nail art science this is
not your grandma's manicure secret
messages that glow in the dark
thermochromic paints that change color
and ultra realistic portraits that you
have to see to believe i was just
sitting at a restaurant and i had dwight
schrute on my nails and somebody came up
to me and was like is that dwight and
i'm like it sure is that's one thing i
love about nails because as long as i've
done this i've not failed to have people
have this like really vivacious reaction
to it it's never like oh that's pretty
cool it's like oh my god
[Music]
okay this is weird but
has anyone asked you to do nails for
their pet
um no not for a pet but we have been
asked to do nails for dead bodies wait
what there are some people that have put
me actually on their funeral wish list
and i have to have nails from vivian
don't disrespect me by putting like
other nail slot or something okay let's
back up in 2016 vivian was working as a
software engineer painting her own nails
during her free time i was doing crazy
stuff like painting arnold
schwarzenegger like the terminator
movies on my nails or like painting
stuff that people just normally wouldn't
really get i see a lot of people doing
like pretty stuff or like princessy
stuff and i'm like no dude let's put
rush hour two on my nails so it kind of
resonated with a lot of different
audiences as opposed to just nails as a
pretty accessory within a few months she
had over a million followers on tick
tock people started dming asking for
various things like can i get this
character can i get this portrait oh my
god can you do that for me oh my god i'm
super into that too or oh my god you
should open a shop or something like
that
i love doing portraits portraits is my
favorite thing to do i've done hagrid
and double door with snape and lupin and
mcgonagall i've done post malone billy
eilish i did do a bob ross grogu also
done mando i do have an affinity for
villains i did the night king from game
of thrones the terminator i've also done
voldemort something to keep in mind with
vivian's portraits her canvas is curved
the artwork then goes on a moving hand
that's meant to be seen from many
different angles i have to almost
architect it so that the positioning of
it is conducive to viewing it from all
different types of angles i've done a
ton of marvel characters thor and loki
wanna max them off the ones that i have
on right now which is all three
spider-men oh my gosh i almost forgot
about my thanos nails i loved that set
because it was the iconic you know him
with the infinity gauntlet i was able to
do a little video where i snapped
my face and character painting technique
is rooted in spatial awareness and dot
plotting i work from the center outward
so that there's room to make corrections
and so what i do is i use different
facial features as anchors for
another facial feature so i'll say start
with one eyebrow and then from that
eyebrow i can swing from one vine to the
next so i'm not just looking at this
overwhelmingly complex subject like
collect data and the more data that i
have the more accurately i can place the
next feature and so on and so forth
the materials that i use are actually
very carefully curated over the years i
mainly use japanese brands of gel paints
as my base colors i actually started off
i modeled my color collection off of a
watercolor palette i figure if real
artists who work on canvas can actually
use just these limited amount of colors
to make everything that they need then
why couldn't i if bob ross can do it why
can't i do it in terms of other
materials that i like to use the freddy
krueger set that i did i was able to use
this nude colored builder gel that is
actually used to build nail extensions
to create this fleshiness for his face i
got to use like jelly red to get that
kind of runny blood look to it
i will use thermochromic pigments and
essentially what happens is the
molecular structure changes when you
expose it to either heat or cold and one
of my favorite ones is something i like
to call my invisibility pigment and it's
something that changes from black to
colorless i painted a portrait of series
black so what i did was because sirius
perished behind the veil i was able to
cover up his portrait using this black
to colorless thermal pigment and when
you exposed him to a little bit of heat
the black pigment went away and you can
kind of see like a white haze over him
and it actually made him look like he is
behind the veil
painting with a brush of only a few
millimeters long vivian's portraits can
take hours or even days
usually the portraiture takes about five
to six hours for just the portrait alone
but when i get an idea that's stuck in
my head i will stay up all night to do
it because i'm not laser focused and i
enjoy doing it so much
moana took me 16 hours the death of
sirius black took 18 hours king t'challa
including the ancestral plane took about
10 hours the anastasia nails took seven
hours the house moving castle took seven
hours little mermaid took me six and a
half hours jasmine and raja took her
five hours this glow-in-the-dark happy
hunt set took 11 hours the alicia
silverstone clueless set took 6.5 hours
jurassic park and lord of the rings each
took over 10 hours once she spent 40
hours on a single set of nails the
40-hour project was a set of encanto
nails the customer wanted every single
character so was the entire family
madregal and it had also their glowing
doors with their powers and their little
symbols and stuff and i also had a
separate section where i did single
nails that pieced together like a puzzle
and when you put those four nails
together you could see that it was the
prophecy i'll put together
today i am working on a portrait of
anakin skywalker as he is turning to the
dark side we're going to have half of
hayden christensen's face and the other
half will be the darth vader helmet
one of the most challenging parts about
this one is that he's kind of turned a
little bit which is kind of tough
because my nail is super curved and i
also have to fabricate some form of
shadows but right now it's just a lot of
blending and a lot of looking back and
forth at the canvas to make sure that
everything from like nostril placement
to placement of a specific shadow is all
in line with his facial features and
because the dark side has the red
lightsabers i want to have kind of a
more distinctive red glow on his face
so these are gel paints uh it's similar
to if you go to a nail salon and you get
gel polish it really quickly dries and
the way that you dry it is you use an
led or uv lamp it triggers a chemical
reaction in the gel and dries the polish
so when i'm working with these textures
sometimes i need to paint on top of
dried paints and sometimes i need to
keep blending and so i'll just leave it
wet and i won't cure until i need
something to be completely solidified
and so it varies a lot when i'm doing
these types of portrait processes
what happens when i mess up everyone
loves to ask me that question because i
move so calculatedly i don't really have
any major mistakes i think it's like i
will early detect if something is going
awry with portraits you don't just look
down all of a sudden and it's like oh my
god the whole thing looks bad so i don't
really make mistakes like that anymore
because i just learned to
check back and forth a lot
why did you do magnum condoms
[Music]
i love reproducing packaging because i
think it's kind of an exercise into how
i can get text to look really accurate
and how i can even replicate like weird
designs on cans or on bottles so i did
magnum xl nails for valentine's day and
i tweeted at them and i was like just
doing my part guys and then they sent me
a ton of condoms and so i was like okay
thank you so we actually put it out for
clients to take which was like kind of
awkward but also really funny at the
same time i'm really proud of that lysol
nail i painted that at the height of the
pandemic and i think it ended up in a
meme and snoop dogg reposted it and i
thought that was the coolest thing he
didn't tag me though but you know snoop
icu that was really cool vivian's
success quickly got her to the point of
receiving more custom nail requests than
she could possibly handle alone so she
began hiring and training other talented
artists to collaborate with i started
pamper nail gallery and we're based in
the san francisco bay area but we ship
nails worldwide we've had people order
from dubai we've had people order from
shanghai we've had people order from the
yukon territory so it's pretty much all
over the place at this point
the requests they get keep them on their
toes there will be people who will make
an entire brochure like there would be
people who maybe like they plan out a
wedding set and they'll like have
reference photos and they'll show me
like their entire life
there was a dad who ended up sending 40
000 photos of his daughter like growing
up and he's like yeah just like create
something you know get to know her and
then like create something or like how
do we do that so it's definitely like
challenging because people like to throw
curve balls it's not just like oh i want
lion king nails it's like yeah i want
lion kings but i also want you to
explore the depth of the relationship
between these two characters and make it
look like the relationship that i have
with my brother and we're like oh my god
like this is actually getting really
deep but for vivian it's worth it
creating wearable art based on these
iconic characters gives her a chance to
create community i would say that i'm a
nerd i think that's something to be
proud of i would much rather talk about
my obsessions and interests with people
and i think that it really cultivates
deeper friendships and relationships
because of that shared fandom or that
shared obsession so that's actually one
of the things i love about it as a form
of self-expression because it's such a
personal experience because i'm looking
at my hands all the time and i pretty
much enjoyed the most out of the work
that i put in and i think that the
customers of mine see that too is that
they get it but it's mostly like they
enjoy it for themselves and if somebody
happens to get a peek at it it's such a
moment of instant camaraderie because
it's like oh my god i'm super into that
too it just really connects people
through a lot of their kind of personal
obsessions